welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode
63 with dr nicole lepera
aka the holistic psychologist
we discussed navigating relationships
self-care
how important it is to take care of
yourself before you can take care of
others properly
something i've definitely had trouble
with breath work
when to fight creating boundaries and
more nicole has just published her book
how to do the work highly recommend
checking it out it's linked below
please remember to hit subscribe if you
enjoy this content
this episode is brought to you by a new
sponsor that looks at mental health in
an
interesting way as you guys know i'm not
a huge fan of pharmaceuticals unless you
use them
very very carefully and then they can be
super helpful of course
i wasn't aware of some of the dangers
that come with things like ssris and it
totally screwed me over
for years this company dha lab does
unique biochemical and nutrient based
blood urine and hair
testing they do tests for things like
zinc copper
nutrient malabsorption vitamin d
histamines methylation
and focus on mental health without
necessarily relying on pharmaceuticals
although they'll also work alongside
your doctor
kind of in the orthomolecular sense with
the code mp1010
you can get 10 off their testing with
the consultations they do online from a
doctor
as you guys know i've researched tons of
ways to get healthy and i think there's
something to
nutrient malabsorption causing mental
health problems and it's worth covering
those bases if you're trying to figure
out your issues
check out dhalab.com code
mp10 for 10 off their services
that involve blood testing nutrient
testing and a consultation
linked below enjoy this episode
[Music]
welcome to my podcast thank you so much
michaela for having me
i'm really excited to talk to you uh can
you start off by giving a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
absolutely and i'm super excited as well
to connect with you i'm very familiar
with the work
you're putting out into the world um so
who am i
i'm on the human side of things i'm
someone who
as long as i can remember was incredibly
fascinated in the human mind
specifically around what made me me and
what made the people around me that felt
very drastically different than myself
them so before i for long whatever that
year
is that age is when people start to
badger you about what are you going to
do when you grow up
very intuitively i was marching in the
direction of being a psychologist
so flash forward in time a lot of
schooling opening a practice
what i started to see not only in my own
personal life but
now in clients week after week after
year
was a lot of disempowerment a lot of
stuckness a lot of inability to create
change so really beginning to unpack
what change meant for me really unpacked
the ways that i was struggling i came to
the awareness
that i really wasn't working as fully
and as integratively
as i could be i developed a unified
theory of holistic psychology really
honoring the mind body and soul and
really
did a hard pivot and began to work
embracing
the fullness of humanity and brought my
work online called myself the holistic
psychologist
began to share these tools and now again
flash forward in time about two years
and
universal resonance and here i am doing
the work
appealing okay what what does stuckness
mean
i'll start really simple i love it i
love it
um so stuckness what it really meant for
me and what i began to understand
is despite incredible amounts of insight
awareness again i was working with
clients that
had a lot of that that were able to
unpack the ways in which they were
failing to create
change you know maybe even going back in
time understanding
the impact of their past experience and
how it was
continuing to to give them difficulty in
the present moment
yet i began to find an inability to
actually create change to actualize
that insight into action so that's what
i call stuckness
i now understand why it is that many of
us as humans
are stuck and that answer lives really
in the power of our subconscious mind
and its desire to keep us in those
familiar patterns
even despite again insight and awareness
that we
accumulate over time intending to create
a future that's different
okay does that have anything to do with
trauma being traumatized and then
repeating traumatic kind of response
behavior
typically that that is where the
stuckness originates for most of us
again trauma that for many of us
occurred very early on in life
and what i believe trauma to be is a bit
more of an expanded definition
than i think what is what is felt about
trauma are believed to be trauma
in the field i think listeners probably
have heard of the concept
of big t trauma those big cataclysmic
moments
the before and after right the instances
of
abuse physical sexual extreme neglect
those moments where you kind of you're
shook and you really do see
you know a shift or a change in yourself
what i saw
in myself was i didn't have those
moments i didn't have a life where i
could point
okay this is what happened to me this
hurt and here's how i'm different
so what i began to understand is that
there's many other pathways
to that trauma and to that dysregulation
that then
imprints in us and lives in our
subconscious pulling us back
into those old habits and patterns
so is there any way out of this for
people i talk to a lot of people i have
a lot of people who watch me who've had
serious medical issues so they probably
would fall into the category of people
who've had something traumatic happen
they're like yeah
that's what screwed me up but not
everybody so
how do you how do you start to come back
from that i had i asked my audience
questions
and a lot of people especially during
the time of covid they're so stressed a
lot of people
responded and said you know i've been so
stressed that i'm having nightmares i'm
having
flashbacks to stressful periods of my
life and i don't even know where to
start
to stop panicking or to
separate myself from those experiences
so do you have any recommendations
for those people absolutely and i'm
really happy you brought that up
michaela in the context of covid
because covet itself can be a stressor
for for many of us
at the most minimum it's what i call a
pattern interrupt
we're not going about our same familiar
routine we're not driving to the office
the same way we're not
we're interrupted in that familiar and
anytime that happens
this is why pretty globally transitions
are difficult from us
for us when we go from student to real
life to work
we go through a bit of a transitional
experience that's not always comfortable
so again we love the familiar
anytime we're interrupted from that it
can disturb us
it can cause us discomfort that's
obviously complicated
by the interruption that many of us are
facing with
with income with with health um right
furthering our threat based response
that's what we're really talking about
when we talk about trauma
we're talking about our body and how our
body reacts by
going into a state of nervous system
activation
that results in fight fight or flea and
like you said and i love beautifully
trauma the trauma of covet the trauma of
life and our insecurity around what life
will look like
going into the unknown is enough to
destabilize us
to answer your question can we change
whether you're the person who
has that big cataclysmic moment whether
it's in your past or now
because you're living it through covet
or whether you're like me and you've
come to realize the smaller consistent
moments in time
that you've around which you've
accumulated this wounding
we can create change and we can create
change
by beginning to cultivate a practice of
the word i like to talk about
ad nauseam which is consciousness i go
on and on about the state of
consciousness
because it is in that space where not
only are we activating a different
part of our brain having access um
to a different response but we're we're
teaching our brain to now fire in this
new way
consistently so many of us are used to
dropping into that autopilot as we say
that we're allowing our autopilot all of
that trauma
to dictate our daily reaction so the
foundational pathway out
is learning how to be conscious to
ourself learning how to be present in
this moment
so that over time we can begin to
actualize new choices
in that moment as opposed to the choices
our autopilot is going to dictate for us
okay that totally makes sense are there
physical things somebody can do
to stop themselves from reacting in a
way that they're used to
so trying to stop the maybe freak out
moment
yeah the physical things michaela are
the things that we want to do we
actually
i had a workshop this morning with
myself healer circle
and we talked about how ineffective we
are at just powering our way through
thought
right at thinking the next time i'm
gonna be calmer the next time that
activating moment happens and i'm gonna
respond in this new way
that's that's fine and great and
thoughts are powerful
i have a whole chapter in my book about
the power of belief
simply a practice thought however we
spoke this morning and we'll speak about
now how important it is to teach
our bodies a new reaction so to do the
physical things
first to learn how to safely drop into
our bodies
for those of us that have experienced
trauma being in our physical self in our
skin
can feel downright intolerable can feel
like the most
unsafe place to be so we don't want to
dive into the deep end and just grin and
bear it and be in a body that's
unsafe feeling we want to veg very
gradually
learn how to interact with our physical
presence
be in our body the way we can do that
is by using our senses by using our
breath
as focal points for our attention and
the reason why that's powerful is there
too
when we can use when we can hook our
attention on something
that's not our mind our thinking mind
which often takes us out of our body
if we can hook our attention on
something that we're physically present
to we can become embodied we can step in
to our being in that moment so the two
hooks that i like to talk about for our
attention
that can be helpful are our breath
so the ever present act of breathing
that we're doing anyway
if we can learn how to refocus our
attention on a particular type of breath
teaching ourselves how to breathe from
our belly area that deeper place
that for many of us is really hard to
even access at first
it's really valuable for two reasons now
not only am i in my body because i'm
paying attention to it as it breathes
i'm paying attention i'm activating my
parasympathetic nervous system
the nervous system that can actually
help down regulate my body's
physiological responses so for me
that's the number one tool i'll always
talk about because we're always carrying
our breath around with us
giving us that focal point to not only
embody ourselves
but the more consciously aware of our
breath we can become and the more we can
harness that deeper belly breathing
we can actually create safety now in
that body
okay so that's kind of like wim hof
style
wim hof style is a little different um
depending on if you practice
his more shallow chest-based breathing
that might be a little more activating
of our sympathetic nervous system
um though his breath work is incredibly
powerful i actually practice his breath
work very consistently
in addition to the deeper belly breath
so youtube is a great i have my own
resources so anyone who follows me
probably has seen videos that i've put
up around breath work that you can
access
and also youtube there's many different
practitioners and many different types
of breath
so my suggestion is pick one that feels
the most approachable
and begin there start with one that
you'll actually do
start with one that you'll do which is
why i'm always the deep belly breath
because for me
that was one i would do because i didn't
need to carve out
time in a practice where i'm sitting
because that felt overwhelming when i
first began
for me it was just reminding myself i
could do it while i'm walking
while i'm sitting here with you oh a
belly breath right
and now i've done my practice so yes
anyone that feels approachable and that
you can
practice consistently because here's the
caveat that we all love to hate
as as humans we really only want to do
that deep belly breathing when we need
it
the next time i'm in a conflict with my
partner i'll call on it as i need it and
hope it works
we're never going to remember to do it
and we're not probably going to be
successful
at using that tool at that time so
here's where my again suggestion is
practice
all of the time so that we can set
ourselves up to succeed
when we really need it as we're feeling
that subconscious become activated
it sounds like something i certainly
would have underestimated
you know just breathe because you get
told when you're fighting with someone
sometimes
just like calm down breathe and it
sounds like it's that kind of thing but
from what i've read about breathing it
makes a huge difference so how does it
work and how fast does it work and why
exactly
does taking these deep breaths actually
do anything
yeah i love that uh acknowledgement i
think a lot of us have maybe been told
and not the
most helpful and and if we're honest it
can feel incredibly invalidating
if you have been barked at calm down use
your breath breathe
um you know it's a very disempowered
place let me put it that way to be
in that state of reactivity i'll just
speak for myself
it is very out of control feeling after
the fact
many of us myself included can carry
shame about the reactions that were
elicited in that moment i know for me
there's been many moments where i i like
think to myself how much i didn't
mean per se the things i was saying and
doing
so it can be a very out of control place
and very well intentionally i think
maybe those around us you know
share that just breathe just calm down
and it's just not so
easy and i like you i think i diminished
it i don't think i understood how
impactful it can be
for it to be impactful like i said we
really want to with all of these tools
that i
share we're really aiming at the
consistent
use of them meaning integrate this
into what i now do daily as opposed to
the one-off thing we actually want to
create this into a new habit
so that means like i said dropping into
our body
maybe the first stage of the journey for
those listening is just
develop an awareness of your body's
breath noticing
your regular rhythm before we even try
to manipulate it throughout the day
when i began that practice michaela what
i noticed
is my breath really mapped on to my
stress
and as i had a stressful day or as my
stress
elevated in a day my breath elevated to
the extent that i would even drop in
sometimes and notice
i'm holding my breath i'm almost like
like in a complete state of constriction
and
the reason why it's even helpful to
notice that is
when we understand that our body is
sending signals that shallow breath
is a signal and what it's a signal to is
to my nervous system
it's it's kind of keeping me locked in
that state of activation
so even noticing can be the first step
to change
because in that moment if i become aware
of okay i'm holding my breath and i now
know that's not gonna it's only gonna
exacerbate my stress
now i have the opportunity to create a
new choice so those listening
um developing the ability to be an
observer or someone who witnesses
even our physical body can give us the
the tool to create the change so that
again means practicing consciousness
practicing body awareness dropping in
being aware of where you're breathing
from
as maybe the first foundational step
before you then make a commitment maybe
to start practicing
changing your breath in any direction
okay so when you're in the middle of an
argument and you're extremely angry at
the other person and you're saying
things without even thinking
would the first step be like separate
yourself from this like move to a
different room
and then try and breathe and maybe give
the argument a little bit of a break and
return to it when you're not in
this like reptile lizard mode yes i
think that's a great suggestion and
sometimes we do have to
be honest with ourselves when we're
getting or when we're beyond that point
of no return
as i call it know our markers of
escalation so that we can call it
and ask for that time out as i used to
talk about when i used to work in
couples therapy
what a timeout is and this could go
within friendships
within business relationships a timeout
is really an agreement
that when myself or the other person
because we both have different points of
that no return
and if we're having a difficult
conversation either the speaker or me as
listener could hit that point of no
return at any given moment
could be different from the other person
participant of the conversation
so it's the agreement that when either
one of us
get to that point of no return that we
do hit stop
we hit pause we maybe do go to our
separate rooms we do
take care of ourself to self-regulate to
down to bring our nervous system back
into calm
with the promise that we will re-engage
the conversation when
both of us are in a calmer headspace and
i think i'm really intentionally
focusing on that
individual difference piece because
we'll find
i might hit my point of escalation
sooner than my partner
or later and it's really frustrating if
you have a partner who needs to stop in
any given moment when you're just
getting going
but that's what we're talking about
really honoring because you're both
co-creating the conversational
experience when you're communicating so
even if you're calm and the other person
is activated it's only a matter of time
before
you risk falling into that same
dysregulation so a timeout
we we go we separate we regulate
ourselves the way that works for
each of us as differing individuals and
then we re-engage because the last thing
we want to do
is sweep it under the rug and that's a
tendency that a lot of us then have so
the commitment to re-engage at a calmer
time is really important
so for couples therapy how do you feel
about going to bed angry so
is that something yeah no i love that i
love that question and that's a really
interesting concept because here's an
area where you'll hear people staunchly
in either direction a lot of the time
with this idea that we as a couple don't
go to bed angry
um funny you ask i think last week i was
having a conversation
on a podcast about this and i think
that's an unrealistic
expectation you know some
anger cycle some feelings last and
continuing to
possibly stay up all night which is
stressful for the human body
right the more we need sleep um so if
this is happening overnight and if the
decision is stay up all night and hash
it out or
go to sleep angry wake up calmer
re-engage the conversation then
i actually believe the latter is a
better is a better tactic
i'm inclined to agree with you just from
being in a relation a long-term
relationship
it's like that is i'm not capable of
that plus the longer you stay up the
more tired you get
the more irritable the more unreasonable
yes well that's an important piece and
and i i'm bringing that up for a reason
and i'm happy you're you're kind of
piggybacking on that
because our resources how we're sleeping
how we're eating is our body you know
having the nutrients it needs that's why
i'm so inspired by your work really
finding
your body's peace and healing is so
important and when we're
not firing on all cylinders when our
body isn't getting the nutrients it
needs when we're not getting
the sleep we need when we're just
stressed out we're not going to be able
to show up and hold the space
in these more difficult conversations so
in those moments
it's the same conversation we had
earlier about calling it being honest
with ourselves when
we don't have the resources available to
have a different convert
a difficult conversation sometimes it's
better
to ask for that pause ask for the
weekend to sleep on it
and and re-engage on monday as opposed
to just powering through
yeah that's reasonable um what do you do
with people who are in relationships it
doesn't have to be a romantic
relationship it could be a relationship
with parents or siblings or friends
and that relationship has been what some
people would call
toxic is it sometimes is it better for
people to just
leave and separate or are these things
that can be worked through
we'll start there yeah yeah um so as we
begin to heal
i mean you're really touching on i think
the the
the arena that comes comes to light
which is our relationships
right we really begin to look clearly
more consciously perhaps at our
relationships at our dynamics at the
roles we play
at how we feel when we engage in certain
relationships and
as we become aware what a lot of us do
find
is the need or we make a decision to
begin to create
changes to show up differently to create
new dynamics
to put up boundaries as i talk about in
the book which are new limits things
that i'm going to do differently
so that i can experience this
relationship differently
and so with that we do shift we do
change and we do
at times maybe even end some
relationship so
which category all of our relationships
as individuals are going to fall into
that's the individual journey of
creating change of
showing up differently one of two things
happen
the relationship begins to shift and
change into something that's
far more sustainable for both parties
because when we're when we're going into
relationships not authentically
not aren't honoring ourself and our
needs
of our physical body of our emotional
bodies of our spiritual
self before long we become really
resentful
of the people and the world around us
and i did this
myself i would look down a trajectory of
relationships gone wrong
and point fingers at all of them and
what their limitations were
and not feeling my needs in any given
relationship not realizing
that i wasn't doing my part of bringing
needs
into a relationship so as we change as
we show up differently
one of two things happen our
relationships shift and change
honoring our needs more authentically
making the relationship
more sustainable for both of us or
they shift and change and with that some
end
so on my own healing journey and i share
about
um boundaries which for me was an
integral part of healing learning
how to show up differently namely in my
relationships
with those closest to me and i share a
lot about the changes that happened
how i began to show up differently how
my relationship shifted
and how some relationships i made the
choice to separate from
either temporarily and or long term
so it's different the trajectory for
each of us
but really the important piece here is
acknowledging
that we can honor our needs in a
relationship
and if we're not and if we are and if we
do have toxic
or violating or abusive relationships
around us
to create change we need to put up
boundaries and limits
okay how do you figure out if the
boundaries you're putting up
are on okay boundaries or if they're
narcissistic on your behalf
narcissistic in terms of
maybe okay let's back up a little bit
first of all what do you mean by a
boundary do you just mean saying no
a boundary is a limit of any sort we
have boundaries in different areas
there's boundaries around our body
um those could be how much you know
comfort how much physical space
do i need how much physical touch am i
comfortable
with um we have emotional boundaries
what are my limits
what am i comfortable with sharing with
someone else what am i comfortable with
receiving
in terms of an energetic and emotional
exchange
so they're different sometimes they do
involve a no
which for many of us is a very difficult
uh word
in the english in the language to speak
so they're different
depends on what type of boundary that
we're talking about essentially what it
is is a limit a separation
an area where this is my space where i'm
safe to be me
and that's your space where you're safe
to be you
okay so if you're in a relationship so
let's say a romantic relationship or a
close relationship with someone or
or or a parent relationship some sort of
close relationship
and there's supposed to be some sort of
transfer of
i'll do this for you you'll do this for
me type of relationship
so how do you negotiate when
you know you're saying okay you can do
that for me but
no i'm not okay with doing that for you
like how
how do you tell when you're veering into
being
narcissistic yeah in that way i think
it's a good question
and when i think about narcissism you
know the question is
how are we defining it um what do we
mean when we say narcissistic
is narcissism just solely focusing on
the needs of the self
and i'm saying this and i'm riffing on
this because i do see
that a lot of people define any
acknowledgement
of the self having a need as being in
that narcissism
area and i think that's an important
distinction to make
um differentiating meeting our own needs
so that we our cup can be filled as we
like to say
i mean that's what we mean though making
sure that my body is operating that i
have the energy
and the resources and the balance to be
receptive to life amount around me
right my emotional world can i tolerate
stress and come back
down to baseline so in in my
perception and lived experience we need
to
you know acknowledge our needs so that
when we're showing up
we can show up in service of others and
i see
narcissism a lot i see any focus on self
getting
thrown into that camp so that's why i
was asking just for the distinction
and i think again to serve to show up my
last chapter in the book
is called interdependence essentially
it's coming full circle
with me of you know having the belief
that we're interconnected creatures that
we are
actually part of our journey here is
learning how to show up and connect with
the
you know greater collective in service
um so
i believe the honoring of needs
of self needs allows us to then
authentically show up
to receive and to be in service to
others
so it's building that foundation of self
into
a relationship saying this and speaking
this after myself living the experience
of doing it the opposite of trying to be
so selfless
so worried about everyone else that i
actually removed myself
from the equation thinking i was you
know
being loving or not being narcissistic
or showing up in service not
realizing though i was just trying to
indirectly get my need met
through someone else or through my
relation with someone else
i guess there's no point in even
bothering with the that kind of
guilt if you end up just injuring
yourself and then being useless anyway
a lot of us you know we tear ourselves
down based on the beliefs of how we
should show up
and you know the the question of
exploration i offer there
is you know looking realistically and
honestly
of you know where did we learn that
message how did we learn that message
from who
were we taught that and can we gradually
make space
for a reframe of that message and
ultimately yes i believe all roads lead
to
if we don't meet our needs if we tear
ourselves down in criticism if we
aren't loving to ourself we are setting
ourselves up to fail it's going to be
very difficult to be authentically
loving for another human
and or to show up in service for one or
a group of other humans
okay that makes sense i'm going to do a
bit of a 180.
i was on your instagram scrolling around
looking at things i wanted to talk about
and you cover a little bit about
different types of relationships
so you talk about i i'm not going to be
able to remember exactly how you phrased
it
you talked about um being single by
choice
you talked about being in an open
relationship
um let me see what was the other
polyamory
so i wanted to like i said kind of a
delve into
that a little bit have you seen
polyamorous relationships or open
relationships that are successful
in a more long-term form yeah i've
worked with
many of my clients who are in different
you know lengths
of polyamory polyamorous relationships
um
some in their particular relationship
structures for many years most
you know just within polyamory as a
lifestyle
how do we define successful right i
think there we can that's open for
interpretation
um and the point of a post like that
really where we're just unpacking
relationships
is to begin to understand how how much
subjectivity
there is in relationship um how much
what is successful for you or how you
michaela might define success might be
different than
how i might define success even of a
relationship
though i'm of the belief again that
we're impacted by
the messages directly we were given
about relationships which type were
though i don't like these words quote
unquote appropriate versus not
appropriate
a lot of times we're given that direct
messaging where we're told
the type of relationship we will be in
or won't be in sometimes it's influenced
by religious based institutions or by
cultural systems or that were
frameworks that were born into sometimes
it's a bit more
indirect we're not necessarily told
though there's feelings that were given
or the relationships that we're modeling
look a very particular way and
relationships like i said can have all
of these meanings wrapped up around
in them and can be a point where we
either again criticize ourself
for our natural inclinations for how we
feel most comfortable and safe relating
to others
or we might feel very shameful in terms
of sharing our very real successful
relationships with other people because
of how we imagine
they might respond so relationships i
think are one of those
complicated areas and now because
life is lived virtually we're having the
opportunity to see and to meet
some of us very up close and personal
different types of relationship styles
and for that i think that it brings up
it can for some of us bring up a lot of
challenge a lot of those
subjectivities when we even just see or
hear
some of those conversations and i saw
that in the comment section i
sometimes i can predict the the posts
that are you know
going to be activating for some people
and sometimes they're surprising and
that posts in particular you know i'm
always in the comments and i saw a lot
of points of activation even just
hearing the suggestion of these
alternate relationship structures
i like the word you use the word
activating you've been activated that's
funny
i'm going to use that i like that i tend
to use x that's what it
is i mean we are some of us if we're
dropped in can feel it in our energy
i know i can start to feel for me it's
just like i call it agitation that's my
catch-all but i can feel it activating
itself and amplifying
up
so you talked a little bit about people
who thrive in chaos
so or people who think they thrive in
chaos maybe
but what kind of background would
someone who
doesn't feel stable in a calm
stable relationship or environment for a
long period of time
is that personality is that trauma from
before
or what is that adrenaline junkies like
what is that it's likely a combination
of all those things
activated by our earliest experiences by
having so for instance
um i talk about my own quote-unquote
addiction to stress
i talk about a concept called emotional
addiction what i really mean when i say
that is
what has become our familiar emotional
baseline
again that's stored in those pathways
and that neural network in our
subconscious
that is fired and wired so many times
it's it's
on autopilot and it becomes my go-to
so anytime i'm having a feeling that's
outside of that familiar
it feels uncomfortable it doesn't feel
like me
before i know it i'm right back into
those old
ruts and again what where this forms for
most of us are in those earliest
experiences so if you were
born into that stressful environment for
whatever reason
internal to your family system or
external the environment the
neighborhood in which you live
if stress and its hormones of cortisol
and adrenaline
are part of your familiar they become
part of your familiar chemistry
so you could be like me i've been
professing for as long as i could live
all i want is peace man i just want
peace
in my life throw in my hippie side right
however
in any and every moment of peace i
noticed a very consistent habit of doing
one of two things
that agitation would be so intolerable
that my house would be clean from top to
bottom if there was any dirt around
because i had to get it out i almost
couldn't sit
still say in my peaceful sunday or
if my partner would say around and
if i wouldn't kind of agitate myself
energetically
i would agitate the relationship because
lo and behold that would be the moment
where i revisit you know that comment
that was made at breakfast that i don't
love
that she said so now's a great time to
bring it up
before i know it i'm in a stressful
likely
if all goes well conflict so that i like
to use as just an example this could
apply for
sadness if we become so used to the
hormones around low
sadness lack of energy right that could
become our baseline
familiar so going back to that stuck
concept i introduced in the beginning
that is a large reason why we're stuck
we're so
familiar with the thoughts that lead to
the hormones that lead us back to our
familiar avatar baseline that we know as
us that any movement outside of that
is unfamiliar therefore uncomfortable
and a perfect reason why to come right
back
home so that kind of sounds like some
sort of
i don't know if addiction is the right
term
um because it might be more complicated
than that but if you're used to one
scenario and then you're uncomfortable
in another scenario that's are you
arguably healthier right like a calm
environment it's probably better for you
you're probably going to live longer
than if you're just
firing on all cylinders all the time how
do you
get somebody out of that you have to so
again
you'll always hear me talk in two steps
of change the first step being around
awareness
being that conscious self witness seeing
those habits and patterns seeing those
adrenaline seeking moments throughout
your day or seeing that drive to
always be on or always be in that
stressful moment awareness
from the conscious self is always going
to be the first step of creating change
because remember
we need to embody that self to make a
new choice in that next moment
or else our autopilot is going to
dictate what happens
and then we need to practice embodying a
new self
we need to learn how to tolerate more
and more
calm energy in the body how to tolerate
that down regulation how to maybe
do that breath work that we were talking
about when we began
how to be in a body as it's accessing
that parasympathetic that
calming emotional state or whatever the
emotional state that we want to let more
in
of is right if we're sad when we're a
little less sad or maybe we're more
somewhat happy or contented in a moment
right we have to teach our body
how to be safe in that new experience
so it's the body teaching and for me in
my old practice when i was attempting
just to tinker with the mind to give a
new thought to write top down
create change that's what i was
referencing when i when i talked about
how disempowering that was
because i couldn't do it as a human
myself i couldn't just
think my way to peaceful body experience
and none of my clients could either
so this is where we have to unify and
like we talked about teach our body
how to tolerate these new experiences
and i suppose people have to decide they
want to change as well
yeah changes and as i went my book is
called do the work
um one of the major reasons for that is
really highlighting the necessity of
those daily action like we talked about
building that bridge
insight isn't going to create the change
that we're all looking for it's those
daily
consistent actions of doing it
differently
are there exciting things people could
replace some of the negativity with
exciting things in just something that
okay so i have that problem
i've been skirting around it but i
definitely have that problem
i was told uh when i was really ill
when i went to university i was really
ill i was told by a psychologist that
whenever i was in a calm environment i
was just
making myself stressed out or wrecking
something in a self-destructive way
and i was like well things just
continually
bad are happening to me and that was
true right some of the situations was
like
i didn't ask for health problems that
were causing some of these situations
but then when i healed and the health
problems went away
uh life has still been pretty weird but
i have
probably when there's a good period of
time i'm probably more inclined to
get irritable or look for problems or
start something new and exciting that's
really stressful
so i'm like this is a great opportunity
and then i'm just stressed out again
so is there something that i could use
that wouldn't necessarily be as
self-destructive as
poking around looking for trouble yeah
i love that and thank you for sharing
your own experience with that
i think the more grounded and i know
this probably isn't the direction that
we're all looking to hear the answer to
go
the more here now and receptive to all
that is present here now
tolerating because this is something i
deal with myself michaela a lot
there is always something to be done
even when it's a seemingly calm moment
right we know that there's another thing
around the corner whether it's a
positive quote unquote if don't love
that word again right or a negative
thing
there isn't always something coming in
life we're never quote unquote done
as i love to wish us to be we're not um
so what i mean when i say kind of the
more we can become grounded and open to
here and now
without that constant need to reflect or
deflect
into for some of us we like to go
backward in time right and just rehash
rehearse
and some of us like to go forward in
time most of us can benefit from
being here in time and what that means
is then tolerating
maybe you the increasing energy that
you're feeling the want to discharge
right without the place or space to
discharge it so how do we learn how to
embrace
and endure i talk about enduring
feelings
because some of us we do have those
channel points we do have the new
project
right that it that makes sense for our
life in any given moment to work on
sometimes we have feelings though and
energies and there isn't a discharge
place and i think pretty globally we can
all learn how to tolerate um uncertainty
feelings or whatever it is a bit better
by by tuning in
fully to now um because i think a lot of
us are distracting ourselves
um from the excitement perhaps or or the
immersion that we could experience in
what's happening now
because we're always looking for
something else or some other
channel for our energy
so get try and get used to the calm of
it is getting used to it yes
this sounds horrible that's why i said i
don't think this is the direction you
want the answer to go
and though so we as humans we
do want to do right we want to
move into action to solve the feeling or
to metabolize the energy and the feeling
and while that's a great
tool kit to have some of us need to just
learn how to
sit in the discomfort while it's there
how important are exercise and diet
for mindset so i figured maybe maybe if
you have this
energy when things are calm maybe you
need to go like run around the block
a few times well there's where i found
my answer that i
really really hate it um which is that
movement is consistent movement because
i do have that
high energy that kind of agitation and
if i
don't discharge it me through movement
that just piles up in any given day i
become more irritable and i become to be
more reactive so to more specifically
answer your question
for me rebuilding that first
connection to my body because i came to
realize i was
so disconnected i was so dissociated i
called i lived life on my spaceship
i wasn't embodied i didn't know how my
body felt i didn't know
if you know how it uh what food it did
the best on how much sleep it needed i
didn't pay attention
um so the first step was really learning
how to be in my body and once i
did i really overhauled my lifestyle
choices specifically around nutrition
and around sleep
and for me that was foundational i
realized i wasn't giving my body the
nutritional resources it
needed while i believed i knew what was
healthy food versus what was unhealthy
food i didn't
i was eating a lot of highly processed
food i wasn't giving my body the
nutrients it needed
and i still had a lot of gut damaging
gluten type one of my favorite foods
pizza
entities in my diet quite often that i
had no idea were causing damage
to my gut same thing with sleep sleep as
long as i can remember
was really difficult for me i was a
little girl who would lay awake at night
fearful of any bump in the night for me
that translated into adulthood where
i just never really felt rested and i
began to realize how dysregulated my
nervous system was
and how to help regulate help me
regulate my body i needed
to feed my body better i needed to rest
my body better
so for me that was integral that was a
very consistent practice where i made
changes to my nutrition
very gradually over time i made changes
to my sleep and then i paid attention
to how it made my body feel and for me
like i said i believe
um that that's integral in healing
that's why i talk about a holistic
process because a lot of us are sending
those signals of dysregulation to our
bodies either through damaged gut
or over-activated nervous systems given
the food we're eating and or the sleep
that we're not getting
yeah one of the reasons i like you is
because you do that and a lot of
doctors or people you go to to try and
heal you they'll
look at one problem and they'll really
zero in on that and they don't
understand that
the food you eat affects your brain
right not sleeping like they don't look
at the whole
and then you get someone that says you
know journal more or
think positive or something like that
and it's like well
doing that and surviving off pizza might
just not do the trick yeah and then it
gets complicated even further
where a lot of our eating habits
are wrapped up around emotions our
coping mechanisms right it's so
our relationship with food for i would
say the large majority of my clients
was complicated to say the least if not
problematic coming in with
self-professed
right eating issues that's just so
rampant
because we have so much meaning assigned
to food and
a lot of us don't you know have that
again body connection
to be listening to where i believe our
infinite wisdom comes from from our
bodies and yes you go to the doctor and
then
all of our you know we're outsourced
we're just managing symptoms and never
are the underlying causes explored
yeah it's too bad one of the ways that i
started to get better is i finally clued
into what my body was saying
and for literally since i can remember
probably since i was two i was told by
medical professionals to ignore
what my body was feelings and autoimmune
disorder so they're just like
pretty much ignore that and just keep on
trying to live
and it was this amazing switch in my
brain when i was like
oh you mean everything my body's doing
is a response to something i'm doing
not everything but the majority of it
and it was such a relief
it was like oh now i have control if if
i'm causing this even though it's
accidental then i have some
semblance of control even if it's just
like this much
yeah so i've always been just so
inspired michaela by your journey you
know knowing from where you came from
with the symptomology you had and really
creating the change that you did
i cover self-healer that's near and dear
to my heart and in my book her name is
ali
she was really on a pretty debilitating
course of ms
um in her 20s on a flash forward getting
ready to you know look for the long-term
housing unit yikes
where she would live out the remainder
of her years however few they may be
and now with her small daily promise i
talk about that often
really harnessing our subconscious is
preference for the familiar
so to create a pathway of change i
suggest you know only building one small
daily promise as opposed to the tactic
that many of us take
which is change our life from top to
bottom overnight and then wonder why we
can't maintain those changes beyond
maybe
like white knuckle seven days long um
though ally started with one glass of
water and
i mean her transformational story is
beyond inspiring not only is her ms in
in complete remittance um she's
obviously not
on enroute to that housing facility and
is really
creating the life that she desires so
when i hear people
like yourself she found terry walls as
protocol and really just
went on it immediately so that's why i'm
so impassioned about
bringing the nutritional piece up
teaching the collective that our gut is
in communication with our mind
for me it wasn't the medical type of
symptomology
though i collected the diagnosis in in
the psychological world i was
ocd i was generalized anxiety disorder i
had the back pocket of benzos you know
because i had panic disorder
then i was tired i needed to i mean i
was on all of the things
not understanding that those signals
were coming from my very dysregulated
and inflamed body
not the disorder itself
yeah it seems obvious once you realize
and you're like
how could i have been so brainwashed
otherwise but
it's sad it's hard and a lot of us i
mean for me i talk a lot about the
shedding of belief systems of
ideas of self of wellness that i too had
had internalized as mine
um you know i very much believed i was
limited by my genetic
components [ __ ] you know because i saw
the same
patterns and habits in all of my family
i had no other reason to believe
otherwise so
it took me reading you know about
epigenetics and about
lifestyle and the role and the power of
choice that we have
to just you know kind of creak that door
open because for me it wasn't i didn't
drink the kool-aid i didn't
assume that because someone else changed
their life that i could for a very long
time
i thought that i would be the only
person that while all of this epigenetic
change is so
inspiringly possible i can't do it
and it took me living the experience of
creating change
as i believe it does for each of us it
is the wisdom of making the choice of
experience that i believe is our
greatest teacher
though hearing you know that this can be
a message of empowerment that is my hope
is that anyone out there who believed
they were you know limited
by their genetics or or by their
personality or by all the things that
they've been living
so far if one person even just cracks
that door and begins to question
curiously if it's possible again i will
acknowledge you might not
drink the kool-aid like i did though if
you can create change through one small
promise
we can really create in my opinion the
future that we would like
so one small promise that's just one
change that you're willing to make
how often per day each day and i
emphasize the smallness of it like i
said ali's small daily promise was
one glass of water first thing in the
morning before her coffee
it's not about what you're doing though
again i do suggest it be something
that's attainable that you almost want
to roll your eyes and say oh that's so
small i shouldn't even bother
because it's not about the promise it's
about keeping it
it's not about what the promise is i
should say it's about the action
of alignment of showing yourself setting
an intention
and then showing up in action around
that intention
because a lot of us something i talk
about often have a habit of living
in what i call self-betrayal that
non-alignment that misalignment
setting intentions or never
acknowledging what our needs are in any
given moment
so to rebuild ourself and to empower
ourself to create the change begins
by just showing ourselves consistently
that alignment so it can be anything
it just means setting a promise
reminding yourself each and every day of
that intention
i created a journaling practice that i
call future self journaling that helped
me to do that or every morning
i just reminded myself of the intention
that i was going to hold
throughout that day and the act of doing
that every day was that
repetition in my mind for me i did it in
the mornings i found that most helpful
because it was my reminder i had a whole
day ahead of me to then actualize that
promise to myself
had i not began my day as i didn't quite
often in the beginning with that
journaling
i probably would have slipped right into
my autopilot
so it's setting an intention and keeping
it consistently and then you can swap
in you can build on that foundation one
glass of water can really become
whatever you want it to be
once you develop the confidence and the
trust in yourself
that's good i like that it's kind of
like
i'm not going to be able to remember the
name habits
by atomic habits i did remember it
kind of like atomic habits i haven't
read that though i imagine it is
probably very similar
and it's pretty good people want to
there's differing
data out there on how long it's the
question i get asked a lot then too well
how long do i have to keep this habit is
it 30 days is it 60 days
i mean there's some you know evidence
that around 60 days is when a habit
begins to set in place
that's why i really do focus on the
smallness of it
keep the habit until it's a habit keep
that one promise i should say until that
becomes a habit until that first glass
of water is now what you do
and then you could add another small
daily promise so for some of us that
might be the 30 days it might be the 60
days
it might be six months for me practicing
my habit of consciousness
daily was probably the better part of a
year where that's all i focused on was
how to be a conscious
present embodied being so for some of us
it goes well beyond
those 60 days it means until you've
integrated that until you remember
more often than not each and every day
to do that thing
until it becomes automatic until it
becomes more or less automatic and there
still might be days
and there will be days and there ought
to be days where maybe you don't
always do it and the beautiful gift you
give yourself when you embody trust
so now there might be moments where i
don't do my
exact morning routine as i always do for
many different reasons because i don't
want to because i'm tired for many
reasons
i now no longer fear that slippery slope
that descent into i'm never doing it
again and all my symptoms come back
because i now know i have that choice
available to me tomorrow
to re-engage my habit that's what we
really want to work to is that
confidence because the day where i don't
do something because my body is
tired probably is the thing i want to
honor in that moment my tired body
so here's where i insert the reality
that we are ever
changing creatures our needs aren't
consistent throughout every given day
and if you're female and you're still on
your cycle you know how
wild things change you know throughout
life so
the same process each and every day
isn't going to apply to each and every
day
because we're just not consistent beings
so we really want to have that
kind of guidepost that's inside that
checkpoint that we build for ourselves
throughout the day
so that we can be aware of what we need
in this moment
okay i have a few more questions and
this we already touched on but
i guess i need more information on it
how can you tell
if you're being lazy or whiny about
something or like i don't really want to
do that
or you actually need a break are there
cues you can get
because there's it's very difficult to
tell the difference between not being
self-disciplined
and bullying yourself until you're
damaging yourself
yeah that's a really really great
question michaela and i think some
markers could be the consistency
of that whiny i'm tired i don't wanna
we'll call it the i don't want a message
and what i mean by that
look for patterns right do you always
not want to
around the same thing and if it's every
time you have say one commitment
you know or one thing you do for work or
one relationship for instance
if each and every time you're offered an
opportunity to engage with that space
whatever it might be
if there's a consistency and i don't
wanna that might be something
to look at versus right if
i don't want to as a one-off i usually
like to do this thing but today
right i don't want to um we can find
messages in patterns um and what you'll
find as you begin to explore
say your you know your relational
dynamics you might see
that every time this one particular
person makes plans with you or calls you
you get maybe that feeling of some
version of constriction
as opposed to feeling you know free and
like you want to
um and so patterns i think can give us
some
clues because there might be things that
you're doing and you're maybe
bullying yourself into doing that aren't
in alignment
and you'll know because you'll
consistently get that ping
that this isn't working for whatever
reason
okay and then next question if you're in
a relationship
are there things you should feel
entitled to that the other person should
do for you
or should we be focusing just on
what we can do for ourselves what's the
difference between
a couple people asked this actually was
how do you know if it's
codependency or if you're just doing
something for the other person and
they're doing something for you
because you're in a relationship with
them you can ask
the intention i think exploring our
intentions
is something that we don't most of us
don't make a consistent habit
ask yourself why are you doing it that's
the first question
why am i you know compelled to show up
in this way or to do this thing
why um is the reason for me
or is it for you right and that can give
us
some clarity um i don't think we most of
us are aware
um around intention or are aware that we
can start to harness and utilize
intentions throughout our life
so localizing it am i showing up for you
again based on what sort of belief
sometimes we have conditional beliefs so
that you'll love me so that you won't
leave me
um those are you know of that kind of
codependent that i
get my need met through relation with
you through continued relation with you
through love
if i stay um this gets complicated and i
get this question a lot too
around collectivism and collective
cultures and this idea of showing
up right in service of other people we
could go full circle back to how we
began
in my opinion we can only show up for
someone else
authentically in service if we're
aligned and connected
so the steps to that like we talked
about are
acknowledging our needs are filling our
own cup or taking care of ourselves
first then we have the space
to care for someone else to show up
in support of to be receptive to a need
that someone else might
have in any given moment so it's not
mutually exclusive we do have to honor
our needs and someone else's and create
the space in us
and in the relationship for both when
we're erring on the codependent end of
things
our side of the equation is typically
removed
right my knee gets met through service
to you only
not through my action of my own accord
so we want to
create space for both okay last question
then i'll let you go
if you're in a relationship with someone
who's codependent or you're the one
who's codependent
how do you stop being codependent
very good question and i've lived that
experience as a recovering codependent
myself so as always awareness is key
understanding those patterns the
thoughts the beliefs
right those pulls of to act in that
codependent way
and then within that new space that
conscious space that we're all carving
out as we practice consciousness
right as we be sit in self witnessing
seeing those moments
we want to begin to be more honoring of
ourselves so for some of us that are
codependent that means spending a little
more time alone
some of our codependent self spend no
time alone we're always with someone
else
or again acknowledging our needs in the
moments where they naturally differ for
someone else or when there aren't others
around
building maybe that small daily promise
plan for our own healing journey
in all of our days so that we are
becoming a factor
we don't switch our codependent dynamics
in relation overnight we need to
practice
honoring ourselves showing up for
ourselves so that when it's
really hard when my knee does differ
from someone else in a given moment
i have the confidence to honor my need
and that doesn't like i said come
overnight
we want to give ourselves the
opportunity to practice
so for me being codependent and creating
boundaries especially in my core
relationships with my family and my
partners
was the hardest so i actually practiced
as i say on the periphery
i practiced in relationships where it
didn't feel as threatening
if i were to begin to put up boundaries
or begin to say no
or begin to honor my need in a way i
started say with professional contacts
or people that the threat of losing
didn't feel as as great or as big and
then i developed the confidence to work
my way
in to start to put up the boundaries and
break that habit of codependency
in those relationships where it was much
harder to do
that's a good tip i like that thank you
very much for coming on
where can people find you online if
they're not following you already
of course thank you so much michaela for
having me the place that you will
for sure see me each and every day is on
instagram
at the dot holistic dot psychologist
talking about all these topics of
healing sharing my own journey and also
dive into the mix of comments anyone
who's interested in connecting with
other humans doing the work living the
work
we have an amazing community of
self-healers on that instagram account
we're in the process of revamping our
youtube so
we'll undergo we'll be unrolling our new
season with a new look
in the next couple weeks so keep an eye
out on that and you can search that at
the dot holistic dot psychologist
well thanks again for coming on and all
those links are going to be
below including the book link so be sure
to check it out folks
there it is there it is in all our glory
thank you so much michaela
you